of course we have often deputized
and the remkes report did not lie
the remkes report did not lie
the whole cabinet has damn it
had a huge twist on how
this cabinet
and this minister has dealt with this whole matter
the total failure to show any empathy
what I said here I don't know how many times
and it rumbles on and on and on
and it will be yes
the nitrogen tap must be closed
and nature is about to collapse
greenpeacetal becomes common here
knocked out by this minister
activist language becomes here
farming families
are broken by this policy are broken
I myself know 5 families where someone
a farmer has taken his own life
someone recently
just go totally broke
and do I have to put on a show of yes here
I am considering a motion and I will wait for the
no I am very clear and honest
and I say it right in the beginning
as far as I am concerned,
this minister has to leave
and then I'm not about the person
Mrs. van der Wal
that concerns me about the minister van der wal
as far as I am concerned,
it has to go
and I do all kinds of circu games with this
yes it is going to consider so on a neater
you might get some support then
well I'm not crazy either
I also know that that motion will not make it
finally I take the motion
of suspicion because I think
that this minister must leave